♪ This bitter earth ♪
♪ What fruit it bears ♪
[over broadcast]
My fellow citizens of the world
What I have to say to you
is not something I was
ever prepared to say.
♪♪
As many of you know
by now, we are suffering from
inexplicable and seemingly
unrelated incidents.
♪ That no one shares ♪
Ranging from power outages
to the destruction of
infrastructure and homes.
♪ This bitter earth ♪
We now believe these incidents
are not unrelated,
but in fact connected.
♪♪
What is being visited
upon our Earth ---
Contact front!
[gunfire]
--- is not of our Earth.
[static]
[siren]
Listen to me.
We're leaving. Now!
That's my car! Hey!
I'm keeping us safe.
Safe from what?
Your squad was lost
in an encounter.
Was that your only encounter?
-No.
♪♪
♪ And if my life ♪
♪ Is like the dust ♪
♪ Ooh, that hides the glow ♪
We might be all that stands
between life as we know it
and the end of all existence.
♪ Heaven only knows ♪
The world wants to test us
to see if it can break us.
Help me! Please!
Not today.
♪♪
♪ This bitter earth ♪
♪ May not be so ♪
♪ bitter after all ♪